les salles de sport elles aussi sont
fermées en tout cas depuis le 14
septembre dernier pour protester une
centaine de représentants ont manifesté
cet après-midi à paris des
représentations des représentants de la
profession ont été reçus au ministère de
la santé à l'issue de la manifestation
les propriétaires des salles de sport
dénonce une fermeture injuste mais se
disent prêts néanmoins à discuter de
nouveaux protocoles écouter on est
évidemment très impacté par la crise
sanitaire avec des chiffres suite au
confinement qui sont de dramatique on
perd un tiers d'un style d'affaires site
le premier confinement on espérait une
reprise
évidemment le mode horde de gens de
septembre pardon est un mois très
stratégique pour les salles de sport
comme vous le savez est aujourd'hui on
est à retour en arrière suite à des
décisions qui sont arbitraires selon
nous qui ne s'appuie sur aucun chiffre
la filière du sport toutes activités
confondues est en souffrance
et c'est dans les heures qui viennent
qu'on a besoin d'une solution sur lequel
on est prêt à faire des efforts pour se
réadapter clairement mais en tout cas on
ne pourra pas attendre encore un délai
un certain la situation et cette
fermeture administrative
nous sommes totalement disproportionnée
injustifiée incompréhensible et c'est ce
qu'on a exprimé au conseiller du
ministre en lui disant très bien qu'on
était prêt à étudier des évolutions dans
les protocoles
on a entendu parler des discussions
qu'il y aura avec les restaurateurs donc
on est prêts à s'inscrire dans cette
démarche positive et constructive